madame monsieur bonjour et bienvenue
pour ce nouveau numéro de dimanche en
politique aujourd'hui je reçois le
député socialiste de côte-d'or laurent
grandguillaume bon jour en jour alors
cette semaine est sorti en librairie je
vote ou pas un livre que vous avez co
écrit avec votre quasi homonyme laurent
petitguillaume c'est aux éditions albin
michel
alors on va en parler tout au long de
cette émission mais par le prisme de
votre annonce du début du mois de
septembre vous quitter la scène
politique alors pour commencer je
voudrais vous montrer quelques images on
va les voir dans cet écran ça s'est
passé le 19 juin 2012 vous êtes sur les
quais de la gare de dijon hop un petit
signe amical à l'époque c'était un pari
filiale de françois rebsamen
vous allez prendre le tgv
les tgv en direction de paris on vous
voit toujours bouquinant vous aimez bien
les journaux visiblement vous allez en
fait direction via le métro direction
l'assemblée nationale où vous faites vos
premiers pas vous vous disiez muet
impressionné ce jour là est ce que c'est
un souvenir encore très présent oui bien
sûr c'est à dire que c'est d'abord une
grande fierté que de représenter les
citoyens
en tant que député la nation et puis
vous savez moi mon parcours je viens
d'un milieu populaire
je dois tout à l'école de la république
je le moment seul héritage c'est
justement l'école de la république
voilà est donc en fait de pouvoir un
jour être élu de la nation
quand on vient justement d'un milieu
populaire et quand on a comme seul
héritage d'écoles d'art publiques ça
veut dire qu'on peut aussi amener le
faire et que c'est possible alors qu'est
ce qui vous prend de vouloir quitter
alors l'assemblée nationale après
seulement cinq hommes blonde assez court
il en fait je me rappelle très bien de
en 2008 d'une interview dans le journal
mais publique dans laquelle je disais
nous ne sommes que des passants dès 2008
et je disais que j'ai plus ou moins
longtemps
oui mais que je souhaitais je pensais
déjà même là parfois que j'étais élu que
pour moi la politique ne peut pas être
un métier au sens où ça doit rester un
engagement en fin de compte et que plus
on y reste longtemps plus on s'inscrit
en fin de compte dans une forme je
n'allais pas dire de confort mais
quelque part il faut savoir aussi se
remettre en cause
et pour moi en fait mon métier à la base
ces conseillers en formation et j'ai pas
envie j'ai 38 ans j'ai envie aussi de
retourner à la vie professionnelle de
voir d'autres choses de pouvoir aussi me
ressourcer sur le plan des idées sur et
donc de retrouver
voilà à la fois mes engagements
professionnels de nouveaux engagements
associatifs sans pour autant m'éloigner
de la chose publique parce qu'en fait
pour moi je suis un homme engagé donc
toute ma vie je serai engagé toute ma
vie je ferai la politique au sens de
défendre des idées et lil boosie
intéresserait toujours bien sûr et qu'on
est pour moi et lui c'est pas une
finalité en soi mais certains pour ce
que vous bluffer ils ont du mal à mettre
ce qui étonnant en fait c'est que dans
notre pays
en fait compte ma décision paraît
atypique alors que dans tout le reste de
l'europe
elle paraît très naturel dire qui est
qu'en france en fin de compte ou quand
vous retournez entre guillemets d'avis
il sa part est atypique
alors que dans tous les autres pays
d'europe vous avez même des premiers
ministres qui sont premier ministre a 40
ans et qui retournent à la vie civile
regardez cameron par exemple en
angleterre bien voilà il arrête alors il
ya eu bien sûr le break site mais il
retourne d'ailleurs travaillé dans le
privé c'est normal il y a qu'en france
où c'est pas normal pourquoi parce qu'en
france en fin de compte on a construit
le système politique autour de carrière
politique au sens où il faut passer un
bon brevets d'ailleurs de bons militants
politiques montrer patte blanche être
candidat au bout de dix ou quinze ans de
militantisme vous ça a été plus rapide
en fait moi j'ai adhéré au parti sis à
l'âge de 18 ans et j'ai été candidat
pour la première fois à une élection
à l'âge de 30 ans donc les douze ans
après après d'ailleurs avoir eu des
responsabilités locales et nationales et
et ensuite une fois qu'on est élu en
fait on a l'impression qu'il faut
éternellement être candidat à toutes les
élections
ça veut dire ça veut dire quoi ça veut
dire que vous êtes là c'est déjà de la
vie politique à 38 ans pas du tout j'ai
pas là c'est au contraire moi je suis
d'un naturel optimiste je suis con
baptisé la cde d'être élu je sais pas de
lasser les tribus en fait ça m'a
passionné
ce que j'ai fait et ça me passionne
encore puisque je vais terminer jusqu'au
mois de juin oui mais je veux aussi
porté d'autres choses d'autres projets
j'ai par exemple suivi la vie
associative à dijon lorsque j'étais
adjoint ni conseil municipal ça m'a
toujours beaucoup intéressé et il ya
plein de projets que j'aimerais porter
demain voilà est donc toujours dans cet
esprit combatif on y reviendra votre
pendant votre mandat là votre permanence
elle a été vandalisé à
à l'occasion des manifestations de la
loi travail est ce que ça vous a porté
un coup aussi ça faisait dix offres
personne ne comprend rien aux non pas du
tout après vous savez ce sont des
comportements ultra minoritaire il a
devaient tous les manifestants qui
reprochent au gouvernement de ne pas
avoir écouté qui n'est pas eu
suffisamment de dialogue social
et c'est vrai peut pas dire que c'était
une réussite du point de vue du dialogue
social après vous avez des comportements
minoritaires qui ont cassé effectivement
une permanence ça sert à rien d'ailleurs
j'ai eu que une demande de rendez vous
au départ de trois lycéens qui sont
venus me rencontrer et une demande de
rendez vous une fois que la loi a été
votée
entre-temps en fait je n'ai pas reçu de
demandes auront du mal mais c'est pas ça
qui m'a en quelque sorte provoquer je ne
sais quelle décision parce qu'en fait
j'ai toujours pensé quelque part j'ai
toujours voulu rester anonyme libre moi
je veux rester libre libre d'abord de
dire ce que je pense ce que j'ai
toujours fait je la mettais frondeurs
par contre j'ai toujours dit ce que je
pensais ce qui m'a amené parfois même à
voter contre certains projets de loi
dans la majorité
et moi je veux rester libre je veux
pouvoir dire en fait ce qui ne va pas je
veux pouvoir m'indigne moi j'ai pas
envie que ma capacité d'indignation
elles se réduisent à mesure en fin de
compte que je m'installe dans une forme
de confort mais est ce que vous avez
est-ce que c'est aussi par déception
quelque part déception de ne pas pouvoir
agir assez vive déception de ce qu'a
fait ce gouvernement
j'ai eu des regrets sur certains points
c'est vrai mais c'est pas ça qui m'amène
à prendre cette décision aujourd'hui des
de regrets lesquels par exemple quand on
a mis en place le non cumul des mandats
moi je me suis par exemple engagé pour
être candidat aux législatives dans ma
pikine non cumul des mandats au
lendemain des initiatives vous on n'a
pas été beaucoup à le faire pourtant les
frais d'engagement premier point
deuxième point après il ya eu des
oppositions pour appliquer cette mesure
au sein même de la majorité
après on s'était engagé à mettre en
place le vote des étrangers aux
élections locales
on n'est pas allé au bout des choses
mais j'avais signé une tribune nalité
2012 avec une centaine de députés pour
dire inscrivant le débat même si on est
minoritaire mais allons jusqu'au bout on
avait pris l'engagement
ensuite j'ai défendu une loi contre le
chômage longue durée j'ai mis trois ans
à pouvoir justement à arriver au bout
parce qu'il y avait des résistances et
des conservatismes
donc oui c'est un excellent long et
qu'en même temps il y a eu peut-être
voilà des éléments qu'on n'a pas
respecté en même temps il ya eu des
réussites on a mis en place sa garantie
jeanne on a mis en place différentes
mesures
ils vont plutôt dans le sens de la
justice sociale on a quand même fait de
belles choses même si il y à des ombres
il ya quand même des lumières dans ce
bilan alors des regrets quand même mais
est-ce que parmi les regrets il ya aussi
le fait de ne pas avoir été appelé au
gouvernement vous avez été plus d'une
fois pressenti est ce que vous vous êtes
pas dit voilà je suis pas remercie pour
tout le boulot que j'ai fait parce que
vous avez été quand même sur pas mal de
missions vous allaitez mise en avant on
va dire par cette majorité
je n'ai jamais rêvé d'être ministre
d'ailleurs par as pu envoyer devant je
vais pas me raser jouer les pensées
avant ma part oui mais vous papa donc
voulait pas dire que vous n'y allez
j'avais pensé c'était dans les îles se
mettait dans mes ambitions même si ça a
été dans les hypothèses on a parlé dans
l'allée dans les médias parfois de la
possibilité que je le devienne mais en
fait moi j'ai toujours souhaité une
seule chose pendant mon mandat c'est de
réussir à faire voter la loi
d'expérimentation contre le chômage
longue durée qui était soutenu par atd
quart monde emmaüs france au secours
catholique
ça arrive est d'arriver à la faire
appliquer c'est le cas aujourd'hui
doivent être appliquées à la fin de
l'année en fait mais ça ça a été ma
seule ambition
moi je vais être ministre oui vous savez
que vous allez qu'est ce que vous auriez
dit non j'aurais dit non
vous auriez dit non vous avez besoin à
manuel valls il a repris son j'aurais
dit non pourquoi
parce que pour moi en fait je pense que
dans notre démocratie est donc dans la
vème république est une démocratie
brutale par nature d'ailleurs la gauche
n'a pas modifié profondément cette vème
république et françois guéant a dit le
président hollande a encore dit qu'il
tenait à ses deux seins alors que
françois mitterrand parlait du coup
d'état permanent et bien en vendée le
président oui mais voilà c'est bien le
problème est en fait je pense qu'un
député
un parlementaire ou un sénateur qui se
saisit de tous les pouvoirs dont il
dispose
on peut même avoir plus de pouvoir qu'un
ministre sylvania son travail pourquoi
parce que nous avons des pouvoirs à la
fois de contrôle de l'exécutif
nous avons des pouvoirs d'évaluation des
politiques publiques nous représentons
les citoyens et donc en ce sens nous
devons justement contrôler l'exécutif
et donc si un parlementaire se saisit de
tous les pouvoirs dont il dispose mais
il peut faire bien plus de choses qu'en
tant que ministre 6,7 pour être
enseignant se demande pourquoi vous
partez si c'est pour être ministre en
fin de compte
et puis dire uniquement ce que l'on doit
dire obéir en fin de compte
moi ce n'est pas dans mon tempérament je
suis d'un naturel plutôt à digne et
voilà je joue collectif
et j'ai toujours été loyal mais en même
temps moi je veux pouvoir dire ce que je
pense
en fait elle ne pas être
forcément obligé de pouvoir défendre
quelque chose dans lequel je ne crois
pas par contre j'ai beaucoup d'estimé et
d'admiration pour ceux qui comme
christophe sirugue par exemple qui sont
au gouvernement
c'est une fonction très difficile où on
se rend beaucoup de coups et c'est pas
facile de regarder sur le dossier alstom
il a bien fait son travail mais quoi
qu'il fasse à son île serai critiqué
et moi j'ai beaucoup d'admiration pour
ceux qui ont cette ambition c'est une
envie sont saines
non myriam elle comme vous savez ce
qu'elle a dites vous elle a dit c'est
simplement un mec bien en parlant de
vous donc
alors pourquoi est-ce que vous partez au
moment où finalement les français ont
besoin de gens qui peuvent avoir
confiance et qui bossent et dont le
travail est reconnu
d'abord dans mon investissement je me
suis toujours préoccupé de faire en
sorte que après mes investissements il
est d'autres qui puisse continuer les
combats
ça a été le cas quand les démissions mon
mandat le conseil départemental
m'appliquant de non cumul des mandats
céline maglica m'a remplacé elle a été
élue elle fait bien son travail c'est
une femme de terrain et c'est ma
suppléante en tant que député dans
d'autres fonctions aussi à chaque fois
j'ai fait en sorte qu'il y ait qui
puisse justement il y avoir derrière des
personnes qui puissent bien faire ce
travail je veux dire on n'est pas
irremplaçable loin de là donc
et puis en même temps d'ailleurs giresse
pas parce que en fait je prends cette
décision aujourd'hui que je ne fais pas
continuer à m'intéresser à la chose
publique donc donc pour moi ce n'est pas
incompatible
c'est pas la peur de perdre non parce
qu'en fait la scène la première
circonscription c'est une
circonscription dans laquelle
aujourd'hui il ya une majorité de
conseillers départementaux de gauche par
rapport aux conseillers départementaux
de droite
on a fait un très bon score au moment
des régionales moi je serai bien sûr à
disposition de celle ou celui qui sera
candidat désigné par le parti de 6 pour
l'aider et puis faire en sorte que bien
sûr la gauche gagne c'est terence région
et puis on ne gagne que les combats que
l'on aime donc un combat n'est jamais
gagné d'avancé il n'est jamais perdu
d'avancé
après je pense que c'est surtout la
mobilisation et puis les idées que l'on
peut porter qui font vous parler de ce
qu'il réussit ou pas vous parler de
votre circonscription c'est drôle parce
que j'ai plusieurs élus de droite qui
ont salué entre guillemets votre départ
françois xavier dugourd par exemple qui
vous a salué comme un homme libre
créatif et pas sectaire il ya laurent
bourguignat qui a dit que c'était
dommage que vous partiez et puis la mer
chasselas chef de file
de l'opposition à dijon qui vous a
décrit comme un homme honnête humains
animé de vraies convictions qui a su
travailler dans le dialogue et le
respect ça vous a surpris tous ces
éloges en tout cas c'est très
sympathique de leur part et moi j'ai
toujours vu des bonnes relations avec
ses élus comme avec françois sauvadet le
président du département
nous avons des différences politiques
nous aller le problème qu'est ce que
reprochent les français ils reprochent
une chose simple c'est que les élus ne
soient pas capables seulement de
dépasser parfois leurs clivages pour
porter des idées à l'intérêt général
quand j'ai défendu la loi
d'expérimentation a été votée à
l'unanimité à l'assemblée nationale et
au sénat
donc on est capable de le faire et il
faut être capable de dire quand un élu
de droite par exemple avec elle je vais
pas être d'accord sur tout et luan là
s'il fait une chose bien le dire la
cette chose va dans le bon sens exemple
quand nicolas sarkozy a mis en place les
heures supplémentaires défiscalisées
moi j'étais contre le fait qu'on
supprime cette disposition mais allégé
18 en maths appuyé sur les doigts en
disant c'est pas normal faut pas dire ça
c'est moi bien pourquoi ça va bien il y
à des ouvriers dans notre région en
bourgogne dans le bassin minier
ici à dijon wire des ouvriers des
employés des professions intermédiaires
des instituteurs qui bénéficiaient de
ces dispositions
donc plutôt que de vouloir éradiquer
tout ce qu'on fait les précédents
partons des bases de ce qui a bien
fonctionné et puis construisons l'avenir
c'est ce que je pense et ça aussi c'est
peut-être le sens sa politique par
rapport à votre départ un peu de
réaction finalement officielle des
élites gauche à caen et me françois
rebsamen qui a dit il c'est peut-être
rendu compte qu être élu c'est pas
facile s'est pas très bien passé ça
écoutez je sais pas en tout cas c'est
pas facile c'est sûr que c'est pas
facile d'être élu mais dans le même
temps je pense que ce qui est important
en fin de compte ma décision c'est un
acte politique c'est pas il faut pas me
commenté sur de la forme venons sur le
fond sur le fond est ce que les élus de
gauche seront demain incapable de
défendre par exemple le non cumul des
mandats dans le temps est ce que les
élus de gauche par le président la
république par exemple s'est positionné
cette idée votre relation avec françois
rebsamen elle s'est nettement détériorée
depuis un moment vous avez quittez
disons l'exécutif à la mairie ça lui a
pas plu à françois une femme entre elles
nous avons eu des désaccords sur le fond
mais jamais sur la forme c'est un bon
maire qui fait bien son travail
sur le fond on a eu des désaccords par
exemple sur le non cumul des mandats on
a eu des désaccords sur les
intermittents du spectacle puisque je
faisais partie du comité national
justement qui avec les intermittents du
spectacle on a eu des désaccords sur les
heures sup défiscalisées par exemple ou
encore peut-être sur la loi
d'expérimentation quand il était
ministre travaille m donc après je ne
sais pas mais c'est ça en même temps si
j'étais d'accord avec 100% des zones
calmes inquiétant on serait encore tout
le monde sait qu ils vouvoyaient comme
son dauphin comme son successeur
potentiel n'existe pas les dauphins oui
on n'est pas dans une année pas leur
monarchie imaginez que vous seriez son
successeur à la mairie dit en tout cas
candidat à la tête de la mairie de dijon
et on a l'impression que il ya il ya eu
une rupture de confiance non entre les
deux sections de confiance je dire moi
j'ai mon chemin vous nous avez annoncé
que vous alliez démissionner par exemple
je vous dire clairement les choses avant
l'été j'ai vu le président république le
premier ministre j'avais aussi vu
françois rebsamen
je leur ai dit on vous avez vu deux
jours avant et je leur avais dit avant
l'été en fin de compte que j'envisageais
de ne pas me représenter
d'ailleurs le président république m'a
dit à ce moment là eh bien il faudra
continuer finir le travail bien sûr que
tu as commencé c'est ce que je fais
aujourd'hui
mais chacun gérait bien compris ma
décision donc ya pas eu de surprise
d'ailleurs dans mon livre
la gauche a perdu sa boussole au front
bien gps et un livre le premier livre
qui est sorti au mois d'avril on en a
légion dans la conclusion je dis
clairement en fait ce que je vais faire
après c'est sûr qu'il fallait lire le
livre mais j'ai je l'écrivais en fait
hier il a pas de surprise donc tout va
bien il faut oui après je vous dis il ya
des accords de fond
voilà c'est moi je les assume celui
j'assume le fait que je ne suis pas
d'accord avec lui avec d'autres sont
certains sujets et j'assume ce que je
pense qu'on n'attende pas de moi en fait
que je sois je sais pas moi vassaliser
ou dans 1 dans une relation en fait où
je devrais me taire et ne pas dire ce
que je pense je dirais toujours ce que
je pense même demain quand je ne serai
plus député dans votre livre
alors laurent petitguillaume joue un peu
le rôle du naïf un du français râleurs
qui posent des questions et à vous vous
répondez vous en profitez d'ailleurs
pouvoir revenir sur certaines idées
reçues
pourquoi skillman en allant de parts et
bien en fait c'est un livre qu'on a
commencé à écrire à la fin de l'année
2015 suite à de nombreuses rencontres où
je lui expliquais chaume ans que je
faisais du mali mais il ya plein de
choses qu'on ne connaît pas ouais donc
on a écrit ce livre ensemble puis sort
maintenant
et moi quand je vous lis je vais
continuer à m'engager pour la politique
au sens de la vie de la cité
donc je souhaite en fait qu'à travers ce
livre est bien on puisse peut-être
convaincre des citoyens de voter parce
que voter c'est un devoir c'est un droit
et que c'est faire des choix et que
c'est essentiel pour justement
revivifier la réponse à je vote ou pas
pour une interrogation c'est évidemment
je vais tâcher de vous le répéter et
vous l'avez dit sur tous les plateaux de
télévision la politique ce n'est pas un
métier c'est un engagement c'est une
parenthèse une période de ma vie
une parenthèse c'est quelque chose qui
n'est pas essentiel en fait laurent
grandguillaume donc ce n'est pas
essentiel ma vie en fait j'espère
qu'elle sera l'ont d'abord que je serai
toujours en bonne santé et que en fin de
compte dans la vie on fait plein de
choses moi j'ai été attaché commercial
en banque
voilà quand j'ai commencé après mes
études j'ai été conseiller au cabinet
j'ai été conseiller en formation
après demain je ferai autre chose
ma vie elle ne se limite pas au fait que
je sois élu même si c'est un engagement
important même si ça appelle beaucoup de
responsabilités et beaucoup de temps
aussi mais c'est pas ce qui me définit
en tant qu'aide moi ce qui me définit en
tout cas c'est cette volonté de lutter
contre les injustices je suis socialiste
je n'ai jamais mis mon drapeau dans la
poche contrairement à d'autres
d'ailleurs si vous prenez tout mais
affiche quand j'étais candidat y avait
toujours le point la rose
parfois il disparaît
dans les moments difficiles chez
certains c'est vrai chez moi ça n'a
jamais disparu parce que j'ai toujours
assumé mes convictions et je continuerai
à les assumer
même dans les difficultés mais je serai
militants et puis s'il faut aller coller
des affiches pour aider des candidats
jerry coller des affiches où vous allez
notamment pendant vous en avez parlé
tout à l'heure mais elle votre
proposition de loi terreau territoire
zéro chômeur a été votée vous l'avez
présenté notamment au grand dijon je
sais pas si on va en voir quelques
images mais ici même donc à dijon avec
le président d'été et quart monde et du
coup là vous intégrez atdk brad quart
monde sait ça en tant que bénévole oui
alors je j'ai adhéré à l écart non c'est
une association pour laquelle je destine
parce que c'est un combat contre la
pauvreté
c'est dire c'est ce qui a fondé mon
engagement au départ quand j'avais 18
ans c'était la lutte contre l'exclusion
et l'escaut nous aurait autant de poids
au sein d'une espèce que en tant que
député mais qu'est ce que le poids en
fin de compte commander pour faire à
commencer des choses pour faire avancer
les choses comment peut-on transformer
d'un point de vue social économique et
environnemental
notre pays on peut le faire d'un point
de vue politique au sens d'être élu on
peut le faire d'un point de vue
politique au sens d'être bénévole dans
une association
on peut le faire dans les syndicats à
travers les partenaires sociaux il y a
plein moyen de faire des choses est de
faire bouger les choses de moi ce que je
veux c'est faire bouger les choses
moi ce que je veux c'est participer à
transformation jugement de notre société
comment il ya différents moyens pour le
faire d'ailleurs c'est ce que disait
stéphane hessel une époque quand il
avait écrit indignez vous l'après il
avait écrit engagez vous ouais mais
engagez-vous de différentes façons
pourtant vous dites encore ses clients
livrés les français eux en général ont
une plutôt mauvaise image un des hommes
politiques et vous vous dites
l'assemblée nationale est plein de gens
de conviction oui alors comment vous
expliquez que ça que les français ne le
perçoivent passe
c'est à dire que devant les députés la
faute aux médias comme vous taper
beaucoup sur les médias je vais prendre
j'en parlais des médias justement parce
que c'est des choses à dire mais par
rapport aux élus il ya les députés je
pense à un député comme alain fauré qui
est député de l'ariège qui est
entrepreneur député socialiste qui fait
plein de travail sur le terrain qui
étaient présents qui bosse à l'assemblée
nationale mais d'autres parlent peu
parce qu'en fait il ne passe pas son
temps effectivement sur les plateaux des
médias quand on passe son temps sur le
plateau des médianes et à ne pas
travailler qu'est ce qu'on fait on
critique celui qui est en face parce
qu'on a rien à dire et donc c'est
d'ailleurs ce que reproche
les françaises et les français aux
hommes politiques en général parce qu'en
fait ce qu'ils attendent les citoyens
c'est qu'on fasse des choses qu'on porte
des idées
depuis quand les transforme or dans les
médias ni les dires des analyses aussi
pour faire passer vos idées proposées
aujourd'hui on a besoin des médias après
ce que je reproche dans une forme de
dérive parfois des médias c'est que
d'abord il ya une concentration entre
des grands groupes financiers et
certains médias donc c'est
l'indépendance même des médias qui est
en jeu et celle des journalistes
parce que quand vous avez des grands
groupes financiers qui impose aussi en
tout cas qui tente d'imposer une ligne
éditoriale
ça pose problème et puis également il y
a
cette difficulté en fin de compte qui
qui qui va vers le sens aussi de de
l'hyper médiatisation par rapport à des
personnalités politiques qu'on voit tout
le temps sur les plateaux et qui disent
tous la même chose ce qui sont toujours
en campagne mais ils ont peut-être
toujours en campagne ou en tout cas il
est sourd enfin s'ils tiennent toujours
le même discours et critique toujours
celui d'en face
bon c'est un peu léger moi je me
rappelle je donne cet exemple dans le
livre j'avais été invité à un débat
jeunes mais en fait ça c'est un ancien
et on attendait de moi parce que j'étais
jeune que je critique l'ancien pour dire
s'est il faut bousculer générales
énoncées par voilà donc parfois des
caricatures aussi voilà un peu dommage
bon alors il faut renouveler tout ça à
renouveler mais renouvelée commencer par
renouveler en appuyant sur un bouton
s'est renouvelée c'est chacun d'entre
nous a une part de la solution
chacun d'entre nous peut dans sa commune
en côte-d'or s'investir dans une
association recréer des médiations
culturelles recréer de la médiation
sociale peut s'engager dans son syndicat
peut s'engager dans une association peut
se présenter à des élections
pas forcément d'ailleurs en passant par
la case un parti politique à venir
chacun à la part des solutions c'est pas
facile mais ça existe heureusement jeudi
françois hollande a aussi plaidé pour
une démocratie revisité notamment pour
raccourcir le délai de fabrication des
lois pour faciliter les référendums
d'initiative populaire ou encore pour
limiter le cumul des mandats dans le
temps alors ça ça doit vous plaire oui
parce qu'en fait c'est justement dans
les propositions que j'en fait en même
temps vous passer pour le gentil héros
politique face aux vilains méchants
vous élus qui s'accrochent à leur mandat
de moi je vous ai je me positionne pas
dangereux la posture d'un chevalier
blanc qui donnerait des leçons aux
autres
moi je dis seulement que notre système
politique il à bout de souffle la
défiance mais ça de l'état s'applique
pas à beaucoup
le problème c'est pas que ça plaise a
pas beaucoup le problème c'est que si ça
continue
si les hommes politiques et les femmes
politiques continuent à être sourd face
à ce qu'attendent les françaises et les
français
le système va craquer et si le système
craque
il y aura de la violence il va y avoir
des difficultés et donc moi je ne veux
pas ça pour mon pays moi ce que je veux
c'est qu'on réforme nos institutions
pour faire en sorte que l'on prenne en
compte cette aspiration des citoyens qui
aiment la politique mais qui aujourd'hui
de critiques le fonctionnement de la
politique mois dernier le texte sont un
peu paradoxal les français n'ont pas ce
qu ils utilisent leur mère comme député
il réalise toujours les mêmes mecs
qu'ils ont le choix voilà soit bourgeois
on met donc en général ni n ya pas qu un
candidat par élections oui mais on leur
laisse pas beaucoup de choix c'est à
dire qu'en fait vous avez vous retrouvé
les mêmes candidats toutes les élections
qui effectivement l'expérience qu'ils
connaissaient dossier donc abandonné bon
et quand ils n'ont pas le choix ils vont
plutôt choisir celui qui connaît les
dossiers qui a l'expérience pour porter
cela je pense pas que le problème vienne
en fait des françaises et des français
le problème vient en fait de notre
fonctionnement politique et
institutionnelle regardez ce qui se
passe dans nord de l'europe
d'ailleurs des français ils partent
souvent du nord de l'europe et disent
regardez le nord de l'europe sur un
ministre il va manger au resto du coin
il va on va le voir dans la rue aurait
bien sûr il ya des conditions de
sécurité
on n'est pas non plus mais mais je pense
que il ya quand même cette aspiration
est forte
moi je rappelle dans les 80 réunions
publiques que j'ai animée lors des
législatives et de la présidentielle de
en côte d'or à chaque fois le sujet de
la rénovation des institutions est
revenu en 2003 quand il le congrès de
dijon du parti socialiste mais un des
sujet fondamental était venu c'était la
réforme des institutions
mais qu'est ce qu'on a fait depuis en
fait le problème c est ce que ce n'est
pas que les français sentent que les
élus sont trop éloignés de quoi ils ont
il est un peu ailleurs dès que vous êtes
élu paris
les élus d'abord sont sur le terrain
après ce qu'ils veulent ce sont des élus
qui sont à plein temps sur leur mandat
en fin de compte et qui ne sont pas sur
plusieurs fronts à la fois écrit vous
écrivez aussi l'aide dans le bouquin on
ne peut pas changer l'ordre des choses
tout seul dans son coin c'est vrai mais
alors là vous allez faire maintenant
parce que j'ai jamais à une association
et puis je vais manquer les humains j'ai
créé une association basée manquerait
aussi une association c'est toujours
votre loi et qui va justement militer
pour faire en sorte que suite aux dix
territoires d'expérimentation qui seront
choisies contre le chômage longue durée
on puisse continuer à défendre ses idées
pour qu'elle s'applique partout en
france et je serai pas tout seul mais
j'y vais y aura des adhérents il va y
avoir des personnes qui vont m'aider
dans ce combat donc s'impliquant dans la
vie politique active politique dans la
vie de la cité oui d'accord pour moi la
politique c'est l'avis de citer ou
est-ce que vous allez quand même vous
impliquer dans la campagne des primaires
à gauche
alors moi je suis quelqu'un de loyal et
ce n'est pas parce que aujourd'hui
eh bien je faire autre chose que je
ferai partie de ceux qui vont commencer
à critiquer françois hollande dans tous
les sens j'ai défendu françois hollande
même à 10% des sondages je l'assumé et
je continue vous étiez là vendredi quand
apple quand le président et je continue
à le soutenir pour les primaires parce
que je pense que c'est le président
république ait eu quand même à traiter
le plus de défis peut-être qu'on ait eu
à traiter depuis de nombreuses années on
est dans une situation où là qu'est ce
qui fait que les français ne le sont pas
c'est pourquoi ils n'aiment pas les
français
je ne pense pas que les français aiment
pas françois hollande je pense que ce
que reproche peut-être les français à la
majorité ce sont ses divisions
c'est peut-être le manque d'ambition
parfois dans les dossiers mais regardez
prenons l'exemple françois hollande est
venu vendredi donc par les hauts
magistrats
il ya l'école nationale des greffes sont
ils avaient proposé une réforme
justement ambitieuse pour l'indépendance
d'injustice qui s'y est opposé à de
nombreux parlementaires donc l'ambition
a été du côté du prix dans le public
après les parlementaires ont modifié le
texte
c'est ça la réalité donc je pense que ce
que reproche aussi
les français des français c'est
peut-être parfois un manque de cohérence
au sein de la majorité
je prenais l'exemple du cumul des
mandats mais je veux dire on avait dit
qu'on s'appliquerait dès lendemain des
élections ça n'a pas été fait par tout
le monde
ensuite la loi ça a été compliqué pour
la faire voter au parlement donc les
français le voient tout ça mais donc oui
il reproche en outre cela la majorité
donc voulu continuer à le soutenir
oui je continuerai à soutenir il nous
reste deux minutes vous restez au ps
oui je reste au psg renouveler ma
cotisation d'ailleurs et qu'est ce que
vous dites oh oh oh à vos électeurs
tiens qui sont qui peuvent être déçus
vous partiez parce qu'ils avaient envie
de re voter pour vous d'abord j'ai reçu
plus de 2000 messages de soutien et
d'encouragement par rapport à ma
décision
et puisque j'ai envie de leur dire c'est
de leur dire que moi demain en tant que
citoyen je souhaite toujours à
disposition pour mener des combats
contre les injustices que je suis
toujours je serai toujours joignable
bien évidemment et puis qu' il ya encore
beaucoup de choses à faire et que
j'espère que justement les choix qui
seront amenés à faire demain eh bien ils
iront dans le sens du renouvellement
voilà dans le sens de l'audace du
courage est de choisir des femmes et des
hommes qui seront en capacité de porter
bien cela et vous pouvez leur dire de
vive voix le 22 octobre je crois que
vous dédicacer votre livre à la
librairie grangier à dijon 4 donc pour
répondre à notre question initiale vous
n'êtes pas totalement dégoûté de la
politique je ne suis pas d'écouter de la
vie politique bien au contraire je pense
que la vie politique est elle amenée à
se renouveler totalement et en
profondeur par le fait que nous citoyens
justement eh bien on va s'engager
différemment et que l'on va faire bouger
les choses de l'intérieur ou de
l'extérieur mais qu'on va les faire
vraiment bouger une bonne fois pour
toutes sa merci c'est déjà ça se passe
très vite merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation je vous rappelle que vous
pouvez voir ou revoir cette émission est
sûre sur notre site internet
dimanche en politique se poursuit juste
après le flash
jonah francis letellier reçoit
aujourd'hui arnaud montebourg et la
semaine prochaine ici même guillaume
larrivé et galbées et gaëtan gorce
débattront de l'accueil des réfugiés
dans la région
bon dimanche à tous